thanks for everyone who's coming out
tonight especially to our two
grandmasters Lanier Dominguez from Cuba
and Levon Aronian from Armenia we are so
happy that you agreed to do this
considering that you just finished
playing a grueling day of chess960 this
piece by tony roma's rack 11 News artist
who's now living in London and his piece
which was recently created in 2013 is
represented by gold verse oil as a white
versus black and it's supposed to
represent the limited resources and the
fight for them and that's what he's
called chemical warfare through this
piece the artist forces us to consider
the idea that unlike in chess where both
sides begin with the exact same pieces
adding the possibility of a chemical
weapon is an immediate game destroyer
where the actual winner is also the
loser one of the perks of this is that
either player if they feel like their
position is irrecoverable or terrible
they can actually press a button that
will fill this all up with smoke so that
their opponent will be able to see
what's going on and lose a game